LARRY ARNN: We all think if
we were rich, we'd be happy.
But also we know we might not.
And then a lot of people
who are rich are not happy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LARRY ARNN: What did we say
was the ultimate purpose
of human life,
according to Aristotle?
ALL: Happiness.
LARRY ARNN: Happiness.
And we haven't quite
said what that is.
So there's a bunch of claims
about what makes happiness.
They're famous claims.
JUAN: Wealth, honor.
LARRY ARNN: Yeah.
JUAN: Health.
SPEAKER 1: Pleasure.
JUAN: Pleasure.
LARRY ARNN: Pleasure, yeah.
So wealth is obvious, isn't it.
I don't know if you know the
Saturday Night Live philosopher
Jack Handy, but
he's very profound.
And one of his
aphorisms is, it's easy
wanting other people's money,
that's what I like about it.
And we all think, don't we, if
we were rich, we'd be happy.
But also, by the way,
in our heart of hearts,
we know we might not.
And then a lot of people
who are rich are not happy.
And what else did you name?
JUAN: Pleasure.
LARRY ARNN: Pleasure.
Pleasure's good.
We like it.
Can you think, is it happiness?
What does Aristotle
say about that?
SPEAKER 2: He said, it's
the life of fatted cattle.
LARRY ARNN: If you live
only for that and only
in the common sense
meaning of that,
it wouldn't be good for us if we
just pursued that exclusively.
And we all know, something
Aristotle points out powerfully
in this book, we all
know that if you just
went after that
stuff, fully, that
among the things
that would happen
is it wouldn't be very pleasant.
See, I don't think
alcoholics take
a lot of pleasure in alcohol.
I think, in fact, it's
a plague upon them.
And I think that a lot
of things are like that.
So pleasure won't do,
and wealth won't do.
What else, Juan?
JUAN: Honor.
LARRY ARNN: Honor,
now what about honor?
What's honor?
JUAN: Good regard from others.
LARRY ARNN: Is that the
same thing as happiness,
being honorable?
SPEAKER 1: No.
LARRY ARNN: Why not?
SPEAKER 1: He says
that the people who--
or people who want to be
honored in the political life
want to be honored by
people who are virtuous.
So what their-- their
aim is not just honor,
but it's honor
from something they
value more than just
honor in itself.
LARRY ARNN: Gil suggested
a complication in honor.
There'll always
be the temptation
to value the honor as much
or more than the quality that
gives rise to it.
What would you
say, Juan, is there
a difference in dignity
between those first two
things, pleasure and wealth,
and the claims of honor?
JUAN: They have
some good in them.
Pleasure is not inherently bad.
And the same thing for wealth.
There is a place
for wealth, as well.
And so I think the same
is for all three of them.
LARRY ARNN: Yeah,
nobody's claiming here
that it wouldn't be
better to be rich.
It just isn't enough.
JUAN: Right.
LARRY ARNN: And that's
true of everything else.
Now, we go to page 10.
OK, there's a
paragraph at the bottom
says, "but perhaps to say."
Somebody read that.
SPEAKER 3: "But perhaps to
say that the highest good
is happiness is obviously
something undisputed, while it
still begs to be said in a more
clear and distinct way what
happiness is.
Now this might
come about readily
if one were to grasp the
work of a human being."
LARRY ARNN: Grasp the
work of the human being.
What does a human being do?
OK.
SPEAKER 4: "But presumably
it makes no small difference
whether one supposes the
highest good to consist
in possession or in use,
that is in an actively
maintained condition or in
a way of being at work."
LARRY ARNN: And what active
condition means is you
have gone through the process
of engraving on your soul
the possession of these virtues.
And now, they are solid in you,
and you are manifesting them.
They radiate from you.
And what being at work means is
when the virtues are actually
engaged.
And so the epitome of
the human experience
is this active condition
or habit of being at work
or expressing character when the
human being is fully engaged.
One of the reasons
we like sport--
there's a basketball
game tonight, I think.
And basketball is
good, because you
can see them, both the
girls and the boys,
and you're close to them.
And you see them under strain.
And you see a long, practiced
capacity, an active condition
fully at work.
And that's what we
like about sports.
We like to see that.
And that's because a human
being is excelling at something.
What the human
being is made for is
those moments when its
qualities are fully engaged.
Happiness is
ultimately an activity
of the soul that is
excellent in all of the ways
that the human being acts
and also all of the ways
that the human being thinks.
And if you can be good
at all of those things,
you will certainly have a
wide measure of happiness.
And to the extent that
you're not good in that way,
your happiness will
be compromised.
And Aristotle presents that
as just a fact, inescapable.
I'm Larry Arnn, president
of Hillsdale College.
You will find if you look
at our online courses
that they cover the whole
range of human learning,
all the high and fundamental
things everyone needs to know.
They are free,
because we have always
wished to provide sound
learning to anyone
who wishes to have it.